five days into the turkish military
operation in northern syria
the u.s military is pulling about a
thousand soldiers out of the combat zone
we find ourselves as we have american
forces likely caught between
two opposing advancing armies and it's a
very untenable situation
the kurds have been very good partners
in the d isis campaign they were very
good fighters on the battlefield
we obviously enabled that as well but at
the same time we didn't sign up to
fight the turks on their behalf the u.s
administration would rather keep the
focus on turkish president recep tayyip
erdogan
whom they accuse of planning to attack
syrian kurds no matter what
on twitter president donald trump said
ankara will be held accountable
dealing with lindsey graham and many
members of congress including democrats
about imposing powerful sanctions on
turkey
treasury is ready to go additional
legislation may be sought
there is great consensus on this turkey
has asked that it not be done
stay tuned but trump's withdrawal order
has critics accusing him of abandoning
the kurds
even those democrats now drafting a
sanctions bill against turkey
for god's sakes what are they waiting
for right people are being killed right
now
our syrian kurdish allies are being
killed right now
it looks like many of the isis detainees
there about 10 000
fighters are now possibly going to be
able to escape their reports this
morning
that isis sympathizers have already
escaped thousands of them
and here you have secretary mnuchin
saying oh well we'll think about it
maybe we'll do something
president trump tweeting that he's going
to destroy their economy
they look ridiculous right now and those
republicans who
normally support trump's foreign policy
to see this yet again
you know leaving an ally behind
abandoning people that
we frankly told that we were going to be
with is disheartening depressing
frankly it's weak and i don't see how it
follows through on the president's
promise his biggest promise of the
campaign
to defeat isis because i think it is
going to resurge
conflicting priorities in a war zone
with no clear idea
where the u.s troop withdrawal will lead
rosalind jordan al jazeera washington
zenith is with us now from akchakala
near turkey's border with syria so
anything more
zaina on this news from syrian state
television about syrian forces moving up
well the withdrawal of u.s forces from
this
strategic corner of syria really puts
the whole area up for grabs there's more
than
one player in the syrian conflict who
wants to control
this this territory which has oil which
is the bread basket of syria
the syrian army saying that they're
sending reinforcements to northern syria
to confront turkish troops
at the same time the syrian opposition
which is allied
with the turkish government they're
sending troops to the front lines in
mimbij
mimbish has long been a flashpoint town
also in a very strategic location in
northern syria
so really the area is now up for grabs
new front lines emerging
then there's a new map who is going to
get
what the but as as the past few hours
the sdf this is the kurdish-led syrian
democratic forces
they are the biggest losers really
they've lost
ground to the turkish army and its
allies they've lost control of
practically 120 kilometers along a
stretch of territory along the border
the turkish army has moved 30 kilometers
into syria from
this northeastern point and they've
taken control of a crucial supply line
so it's a really chaotic situation on
the ground
what happens next whether militarily or
whether deals are brokered
will really determine the fate of 30
percent of syria's territory
and zaina what about the fate of all the
people in the area
president erdogan has been clear to say
that turkey will
take the greatest of care when it comes
to
civilians but there are also a lot of
civilians
who are on the move at the moment
yes 130 000 people displaced by the
fighting this is according to
the united nations this corner of syria
is populated by arabs and kurds they
have a long history of animosity
which their wounds were deepened as a
result of the syria
syrian war there's little trust between
them the kurds say they have long been
discriminated against by the arabs the
arabs say that the kurds took advantage
of the war
to take to take their lands so there is
a fault line here there's ethnic
tensions
it's not just the clashes that people
are worried about it's what comes next
which which ruling authority let's say
takes control of what area
how could kurds live under arab
authority or kurds do not trust
the turkish government so it's a very
messy situation on the ground you can
imagine the fear
in in people because these people have
really seen
years of war they've seen the war
against isil
and now the latest operation so there's
a lot of fear on the ground
thank you zaina hoda in chocolate near
the border